Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
You can call that number any time.
That number is two one nine two David P two
one nine two.
David P. Here is a delightful caller.
Monday, I'm trying to keep it positive with
delightful callers.
This is a delightful caller who got covid
multiple times, she says, and is just thrilled
to finally be vaccinated.
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hi, David.
This is Garnsey from Utah.
And I just wanted to tell you how excited
I was to get my vaccine.
And I got over twice.
Right.
Positive once in September and one in January
and.
It's quite vague both times, so I was thrilled
to go get my vaccine.
I couldn't be more pleased to finally not
have to worry about that again.
Must be some kind of freaky covid magnet.
Love your show.
Bye bye.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much.
I'm so glad to hear that.
I'm really sorry that you had covered twice.
Listen, we have the tools, my friends.
We have the tools to crush this virus.
We have vaccines that work against the variants.
We've just got to use them and we've got to
use them quickly.
And we'll have an update a little bit later
this week about where we are as far as vaccines
go.
But things I know that there's still a lot
of doom and gloom, but Europe is opening,
travel is restarting.
Kids are going back to school in the fall.
College students at many schools will be required
to be vaccinated.
There are some businesses now saying our employees
will have to be vaccinated to come back and
do in-person work.
We look at the numbers that we're seeing in
countries that are achieving even modest levels
of vaccination.
Look at our cases.
We've only fully vaccinated 37 percent in
the United States, OK?
And we are crushing the numbers there.
Still too high, but they're the lowest they've
been in a really long time.
We are probably.
Twenty days from being at 50 percent fully
vaccinated.
Look at what happened in Israel when they
got to 50 percent fully vaccinated.
There are good things coming up and we should
all be happy about that.
And we should all follow CDC guidelines, as
I continue to do.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The House Republican House Republicans, many
House Republicans are being fined more and
more money for not wearing their masks, which
are still required on the House floor.
Marjorie Taylor Green has been fined and others
have been fined.
Will they pay the fines, is the question.
We're going to talk about that.
A viral video well-known to many in our audience
on YouTube is leaving YouTube and instead
will be selling as an NFTE, a non fungible
token.
Is this the future of YouTube videos?
Very interesting.
And lastly, Rick Santorum has been fired by
CNN and it was over those comments where he
was caught saying there was nothing of value
here in the United States when European settlers
arrived, like other than all those Native
American civilizations, very ugly and also
nonracial, not not empirically based comments.
And CNN has now fired Rick Santorum.
Republicans are saying it's Cadzow culture
canceled, sort of like they did to Liz Cheney
for saying Trump really lost.
So we are going to talk about that on the
bonus show as well.
Become a member two day to get instant access
by signing up at Join Pakman dot com.
Or we're only one week away from our Memorial
Day membership bomb single day membership
special.
Be notified of it by signing up at David Pakman
dot com for my newsletter Monday morning the
31st.
You'll get a beautiful email from me personally
saying, Hey, you know what?
Here's how you do it.
Here's how you sign up for that hugely discounted
membership.
All right.
We'll talk to you on the bonus show in mere
moments.
We are here all week.
We are off Monday, Memorial Day.
I'm going to be so busy processing these massive
membership dumps, we can't possibly do a show
now.
And we like giving the staff a federal holiday.
All right.
See everybody on the bonus show for tomorrow.